now Belarus has announced its four CSR
carrying out exercises with merceries
from Russia's Wagner group that's near
the border with Poland well in response
Poland is boosting its forces deployed
along the border the Wagner group was
relocated to Belarus Following last
month's Uprising against Russia's top
military brass let's go back to Moscow
and Julia shop of Oliver and Yulia we've
known obviously for some time that
Wagner were re-basing to Belarus now
um these uh these exercises along the
Polish border post something of a
security concern for Poland what more
are you hearing from Moscow
yeah exactly we've just heard from
Kremlin spokesperson Dimitri petskov uh
basically is saying that Kremlin called
Poland's actions aggressive saying its
attitude requires heightened attention
from Russia uh just two days ago on July
the 18th the Minister of Defense of
Poland announced the transfer of two
polish military brigades to the
belarussian borders so apparently the
brigades have been deployed there now
just several hours ago as you mentioned
the better Russian defense Ministry
indeed reported that its Army together
with the Wagner military company was
conducting joint exercises in the
southwest of the country near the Polish
borders apparently Poland reacted to
that move the exercises have been taking
place for several days now and now we
hear the kremlin's reaction to Poland's
actions so basically according to
Russian official Andre Carter Paul of
the Wagner group was deployed into
Belarus to
that separates Belarus from Russia's
exclaim of kalinian grad if so the
Baltic states the Baltic states will be
cut off from the rest of Europe so
interesting developments and we're of
course monitoring them here yeah
interesting developments indeed Julia
and Moscow thank you